these are vectors a and b all right
that's vector a that's vector b
which of the following describes a valid
way of obtaining vector a minus vector b
so let's look at our choices right over
here so here they just depicted vector b
just like it's depicted here it's maybe
shifted over a little bit
and then over here they depicted vector
a the negative of a vector a
and it looks like they're taking the
negative of vector a so there's the
negative vector a and to that they're
adding vector b
and then they're claiming that this is
this magenta vector is a minus b
but this one right over if we if we
ignore what they wrote over here what
they've done is they've added negative a
to b
so this is
the negative of vector a plus vector b
or we could think of it as vector b
minus vector a so this one right over
here is not right if we swap the signs
if this was a negative if we put
negative a plus b then we'd say okay
this this is accurate but they want us
to figure out valid ways of obtaining a
minus b and this isn't that this is b
minus a
let's look at the other choice
so you have vector a you start so let's
start at the tail of vector a get to the
head of vector a
and then over here we have the tail of
the negative of vector b so they
essentially flipped it over when you
take the negative of it and so we're
adding negative b to a
and then so if we take the tail of where
we started to the head of where we ended
yes this would be vector a plus negative
vector b which is the same thing as
vector a minus vector b so that one is
right
that is a represent that's a valid way
of obtaining vector a minus vector b